so this is the fourth lecture
for Economics
252, Financial Markets.
And I wanted today to talk
about some really basic
concepts, about portfolios.
A portfolio is a collection
of investments.
And I want to talk about risk
and return, and eventually get
into the core theory, which is
the Capital Asset Pricing
Model, in finance.
But first I wanted to say
something about last lecture.
Last time, I talked about
innovation in finance.
And I presented finance
as a sort of branch of
engineering in a way.
We invent financial devices.
And the devices serve certain
functions, and, in order to
serve those functions, they have
a number of details that
have to be gotten right.
Moreover, there's a process of
invention, and the process of
invention involves
experimentation, and when an
experiment doesn't work, we
forget about it and we move
on, but when it does
work it gets copied
all over the world.
So, I thought a nice way to
transition to today's lecture
would be to talk about one very
important moment in the
history of finance: When
the first real
important stock was invented.
And it was, see if I can spell
it right, Vereenigde
Oost-Indische, I might
be misspelling
this, Compagnie 1602.
This was the first --
Did I get that all right?
I think got it right!
That's Dutch for The United
East India Company.
It was founded in that year.
It was a time, when Holland was
at war, and the government
was worried about the economy
and was willing to experiment
with raising capital to keep
the economy prospering.
And someone had this idea.
Let's start a company
with shares in it,
and let's trade them.
And in the same year, and I
can't write this in Dutch, but
they created the Amsterdam
Stock Exchange.
And initially it had
only one stock.
And so this is called VOC.
OK?
And it was a trading company.
They were going to set them up,
and they were going to buy
ships, and they're going to sail
all over the world, and
they were going to trade
in various commodities.
So, it sounds pretty basic.
But no one had ever
done this before.
So, it's interesting how
much got invented in
this one year, 1602.
First of all, they invented
a corporate logo.
I don't know if I
have it right.
It was something like V-O-C,
I don't know if I did that
right, just like we would put
on, you know, advertisements
for a company today.
Maybe that's not
very important.
But what's really important,
also, is that this was a
long-term venture.
There were lots of ventures
already in Europe, where a
group of merchants would get
together and they would pool
their money for one trip.
They would send ships out, and
these ships would trade and
come back, and then they'd
dissolved the whole thing.
But this was different.
This one was going to
go indefinitely.
And in their initial
announcement, they said, we're
going to set up operations
all over the world.
We're going to have an office
in India, and another one, I
don't know, in Indonesia,
and, it's a big thing.
And in the new world, in
America, but primarily East
India, from the name.
But the interesting thing is
they set up a stock exchange
to trade shares in it.
And the stock exchange
arranged that you
could trade every day.
So, there was lively trading.
This was part of the idea.
Because when they set up a
company in those days, you
could get your shares when they
founded the company, and
that was it, right?
I mean, you couldn't trade
them, or maybe you could
infrequently.
The company might open its books
once a year, and they
would take new shareholders
in.
But someone had -- hey,
this is an idea.
Even though the VOC doesn't open
its books regularly, we
can trade them every day.
What difference does it make?
You know, so we're going to
have stockbrokers on the
Amsterdam stock exchange.
And maybe they'll own some
shares in VOC, OK?
And then they'll have an
inventory of shares.
And then somebody wants
to buy some, you buy
them from the broker.
You don't have to contact
the company.
And then the broker will, you
know, maybe at the year end,
will report to the company
that you own the shares.
But doesn't have to, right?
A broker does it.
All right.
So, the broker says you
own these shares.
You trust the Amsterdam Stock
Exchange, because they have
rules and code of ethics, so you
think you own, well, you
do own VOC shares if you
buy them from a broker.
The VOC doesn't know it yet,
but you've got the shares,
because the broker is a member
of the Amsterdam Stock
Exchange and says that
you have the shares.
Then, almost immediately after
1602, a funny thing happened.
Can you guess what it was?
The brokers started selling
more shares
than they had, right?
What's to stop them
from doing that?
Or some of them did
that, right?
So, the broker maybe owns some
shares in VOC and he gets lots
of buyers and the broker ends
up selling more, more shares
than he has.
And he thinks, well, I'll get
them later, you know.
Well, and he says, what do my
customers care, if they own
shares, because I don't
report to the
company right away anyway.
I'll make good on this.
I'm a broker.
I know what to do.
I'll buy them later
and I'll get them.
So, you see what starts
to happen?
There are more shares out there
being traded than there
exists in the company, because
the broker is selling shares
that he doesn't own.
And so there began in, way back,
even in this time, there
began what we call short-sales,
short-interest.
It happens when you set up a
stock market and you allow,
well, we would call it today
street name, owning a stock in
street name.
We have stock exchanges, many
stock exchanges in the world
today, and they, including --
By the way, the Amsterdam Stock
Exchange is the oldest
stock exchange in the world
and it's still trading.
But it has merged.
First, it merged with Brussels,
and Paris, and now
they're called Euronext
Amsterdam.
But they're still doing this.
Nothing stopped them
in over 400 years.
They keep doing it.
But this stock exchange, and
many others like it, allows
brokers to sell you stocks in
what's called street name, OK?
And what that means is that
when you buy shares, the
broker puts in your account that
you own these shares, but
the company doesn't know it,
because the actual ownership
is registered in the name
of the broker, OK.
And so, the broker is
selling you shares.
And it's only through the broker
that you know that you
have shares.
So, the broker on the stock
exchange may be short.
May have sold more shares
then he or she has.
That's all right, OK?
It happened as long ago as right
from the beginning of
the stock market.
There was a scandal.
I was reading the history of
this, and, who was the guy?
Isaac La Maire, a Dutchman,
in 1609.
He was not a broker, he
was a businessman.
He was able to sell more
shares than he had.
So, he had negative --
A broker allowed
him to do that.
And so, he had a short-interest
in VOC, massive
short-interest. And people who
own VOC shares started
thinking, what's
going on here?
Someone is selling, he's
borrowing shares from a broker
and selling them.
That tends to bring
down the price.
And there was a downward
movement in the Amsterdam
stock market.
And this guy was blamed for
having shorted the stock, and
forcing down the price.
And so, the Amsterdam Stock
Exchange, for two years from
1609 to 1611, banned
short-selling, but then they
decided to let it go again.
The point of all this
discussion --
I'm telling you a story about
Holland 400 years ago, but the
reason I'm telling you the story
is to try to emphasize
how certain things just
happen naturally.
Once you set the framework up,
you set up a big company, and
it's a company that lasts
a long time, OK.
It's very valuable.
Anybody can buy shares in it,
OK, so it's democratic.
And the value is very uncertain,
because this
company is going to be in
business into the far future.
And it's building a whole
arrangement, an empire of
trading posts and ships, and
who knows what it's worth.
So, the price is very uncertain,
and buying it is
sort of a gamble.
And so, the price starts
fluctuating wildly.
And it attracts all kinds of
interest. And some people
think it's going to go up, and
some people think it's going
to go down, and they start
debating about this, and
wondering about this.
And some guy like Isaac La Maire
thinks it's going to go
down, so he wants to
short the stock.
He wants to sell, he doesn't
want to buy it, he wants to
short it, so he can have
a negative quantity.
Other people are really positive
and excited about it,
and they want to buy
all they can get.
And they want to even
buy more than can.
They want to borrow money
to buy the stock.
So, you have this tension
between the shorts like Isaac
La Maire and the gung-ho traders
who want to buy it.
And it creates a lot of
volatility in the market.
But the whole effect of
this is to create
interest in the stock.
So, it brings in money.
And it ultimately made the VOC
very successful, because so
many people wanted to give money
to this trading company.
So, they were able to build
hundreds of ships, and set up
big outposts all over.
And it became very valuable.
And it was an invention, kind
of a social invention.
I'm thinking, it's kind
of analogous.
We have recent inventions
that we think
about, the social media.
We have, you know, Facebook and
other recent inventions.
This was an invention
like that.
It was an invention that
got people together and
communicating and excited
about something.
And it created a sort of a game
that people were playing
that turned out to
be productive.
That's why it was copied
all over the world.
So, the core concepts which
began in Holland in 1609 are
everywhere now.
Every country of the
world has this.
I should also add, by the way,
that VOC was a limited
liability corporation.
Amazing.
When I told you that limited
liability came in
in 1811 in New York.
I think I qualified that.
It used to be that some
companies had in their charter
an agreement with the
government, that the
stockholders had limited
liability.
What came in in 1811 in New York
was a law that said all
companies are limited
liability.
And moreover, anybody in the
world can start a -- well,
anyone in New York can start a
company, and it will always be
limited liability.
So don't worry, you can
invest in any company.
And you do not need to worry
about being sued for the debts
of the company.
Well, back then, Holland didn't
go that far, but they
did create one company that did
have limited liability.
So what that meant was, you
could invest in this company,
and it's just a game,
you know?
I can't lose more than
I put into it.
And if these guys turn out to be
crooks and some of them are
hanged for their crimes, no
problem with me, because I'm
an innocent investor.
The law doesn't require that I
investigate, you know, whether
the guys who run the company
are really honest. Let's
protect investors.
So, all you can lose is
the money you put in.
So, it created a tremendous
opportunity.
It was talked about, because the
stock price went up and up
and up, and it made people
rich who invested in it.
But it was also very volatile.
It went up and down.
People had never seen anything
like this before, because
nothing was so actively traded,
and had such an
interesting story that you can
change your mind about from
one day to the next.
Anyway, I didn't want
just tell stories.
This is a story, though, that
illustrates our last lecture.
It was a breakthrough
innovation.
It was a kind of gambling,
but not gambling.
It was gambling on
real things.
And so, you know, people like to
gamble, but, you know, it's
usually a waste of their time.
This is not a waste time.
This was setting up trading
around the world.
And so, it was important,
it was a very important
innovation.
But now I want to use it as a
lead-in to the main theme of
this lecture, which is about
portfolio management and risk.
And the first concept I wanted
to talk about is leverage.
Well, and also let me add
the equity premium.
These are the two
main concepts.
Maybe I'll do equity premium
first. Here's the conundrum
that people were
presented with.
And I'll stay on the VOC story,
but it's much more
general than that.
VOC, after a few years out,
people thought, you know, this
company is amazing.
It's just growing so fast, it's
making so much money, it
might have a really high return,
like unbelievably
high, like 20% a year,
or even more, but
let's say 20% a year.
And that's what generated
excitement.
But some people wondered,
well, how can it be?
Maybe it's earned 20%, but how
can it consistently do that?
So, let me put ''puzzle.'' We've
gone through 400 years
of history since the VOC
was established.
And since then, it seems to be
remaining true that companies'
shares do extremely well.
And that's a puzzle.
Because you know, if you can
make a high return on some
investment, wouldn't you think
that enough people would flock
into the investment, so
that it no longer --
you know, too many people trying
to do this, so it's no
longer performing so well?
But in fact, it seems like the
average return on stocks has
been very high.
This is a theme in Jeremy
Siegel's book Stocks for the
Long Run, which I have on the
reading list. Siegel has data,
doesn't go back to 1602,
but it goes back to
the nineteenth century.
And he says that the geometric
average return, annual return,
on the United States stock
market from 1871 to 2006 was
6.8% a year, corrected
for inflation.
That's 6.5% a year
after inflation.
So, if you're at 3% or
4% inflation, right,
that's 10% a year.
Let's compare that with
short-term governments, which
are the safest thing in
the United States.
The average real return on them
was only 2.8% a year.
So, the difference
is 4% a year.
So, for well over 100 years in
the United States, stocks
performed extremely well.
Moreover, he points out there
was no 30-year period since
1831 to 1861 when stocks
under-performed either
short-term or long-term bonds.
So, the stocks have been
good investments.
What do we make of that?
Don't people learn?
You'd think if people learn,
they would all want to do the
good thing.
Why does anyone invest
in something else?
That was the puzzle here.
It's not just a United
States phenomenon.
The London Business School
professors Dimson, Marsh, and
Staunton wrote a book called The
Triumph of the Optimists.
That is, optimists about
the stock market.
And they looked at the equity
premium in many different
countries around the world.
And they found that all of the
countries, and this is looking
over much of the twentieth
century, all of the countries
had an equity premium, that the
stocks did better than the
bonds of that country.
The lowest of the countries
they studied was Belgium,
which had an equity premium of
only 3%, and the highest was
Sweden, which had an equity
premium of 6%.
So, that's an interesting
question.
How can it be that some asset,
namely stocks, outperform all
other assets.
That comes up then to, what
is the standard answer?
Why is it?
And standard answer is risk.
Stocks are riskier.
The price jumps up and down from
day to day, so the extra
return is a risk premium.
That is what I want to pursue
today in this lecture.
Does that explain the
equity premium?
How should we think about
the equity premium?
So, what I'm going to do is,
feature the theory that was
originally invented by Harry
Markowitz when he was a
graduate student at the
University of Chicago.
And shortly after he was a
student, in 1952, he published
a classic article in the Journal
of Finance that really
changed the way we think
about risk in
finance, changed it forever.
It gets back at this core idea,
you know, people looking
at, going back to the days of
the VOC, people had the idea,
you know I think stocks are
the best investment.
OK, I'm writing that down, and
I'm putting it in quotation
marks, because it's not a
term that I would use.
What is the best investment?
Well they say, look,
the VOC is just
returning tremendous amounts.
Any smart person would just
put as much as he can into
that investment.
Something seems wrong
about that.
I mean, it can't
be true that --
so what Markowitz --
when I went back and read his
Journal of Finance article in
1952, it's kind of remarkable to
me that what he was talking
about wasn't known
yet in 1952.
He was getting at this core
idea of what's the best
investment.
And how do you judge what's
the best investment.
And judging from his article,
to me it sounded
so basic and simple.
Of course, I've studied
finance.
But it seemed odd to me
that everyone didn't
know that in 1952.
So let me --
the question is --
I'll kind of paraphrase
what Markowitz says.
Let's imagine that you've
got a job as a
portfolio manager, OK?
And you're kind of
mathematically inclined.
And you know numbers, and
statistics, and you know how
to compute standard
deviations and
variances, things like that.
So, what is the first
thing you do?
You're a numbers person,
OK, or a math person.
But now imagine you've been
entrusted with managing a
portfolio for some investor.
And the investor gives you a
horizon, and you know, let's
say you're managing
it for one year.
OK?
And you're thinking, all right,
what should I do?
Well, I want to collect data on
every possible investment I
could make.
Not just stocks and bonds, but
real estate, commodities,
whatever, OK?
And I can for each of these --
I can compute what the average
return was on those
investments.
OK?
And I can compute the variance,
and I can compute
the covariance and correlation,
right?
So Markowitz, do you see it?
I've got all the data.
Now I could say, I don't
believe these data are
relevant to the future, because
I'm smarter, or I can
predict that some company's
going to do better than it did
in the past, or some asset class
will do better than it
did in the past.
But let's step back.
Let's do it basic.
Let's just think like a
mathematician here, all right?
Let's just take as given all the
historical average returns
and variances and
co-variances.
And Markowitz says, well what's
the best portfolio
given that?
Ok?
I could compute all
these numbers.
What's the best assembly
of all these things?
And you know, he realized
that nobody had ever
thought like that.
Isn't that a well-defined
problem?
I give you all the variances,
I give you all the
covariances, I give you all
the average returns.
And I say, let's just assume
that this is going to continue
like this, what should
I do as an investor?
And it's funny, Markowitz said,
he was reminiscing.
He won the Nobel Prize later.
And deservedly, I think.
This was a breakthrough idea.
He said as a graduate student
he was chatting with someone
in the hallway and thinking
about this.
And he said, it suddenly
hit me as an epiphany.
If I have these statistics, I
ought to be able to compute
the optimal portfolio.
It's mathematical, right?
It's just one thing.
What is the optimal portfolio?
It took him like two or
three days to figure
the whole thing out.
You know, it's almost
like, haven't I set
it up in your mind?
You see the problem.
You could figure this
out too, right?
You put your ingenuity
onto it.
The funny thing is,
nobody thought
about it before Markowitz.
So actually, I was intrigued
by that.
So,, I went back trying to find,
what people were talking
about before 1952.
And we have a new thing on the
web, relatively new, called --
you ever play with this?
It's called
ngrams.googlelabs.com.
And what you can do is, you can
put in any phrase you want
and search it for the, it goes
back like 400 years.
In English, you can't
do Dutch.
I don't think.
Maybe you can do that, too.
I didn't try.
And you can start to see
what people were
talking about in books.
They have all these books
scanned in now.
Now you can search
for key words.
And so, I did a search on
''portfolio analysis.'' That's
what this is all about, right?
Figuring out what the optimal
portfolio of stocks, bonds,
commodities is.
Hardly anyone even used
the term before 1952.
I guess, it didn't exist. There
was no theory of --
you try to imagine.
How can that be?
I mean, you had all these
sophisticated banks in finance.
They had no theory of
portfolio analysis.
And I looked at portfolio
variance, portfolio return.
It all started with
Harry Markowitz.
Again, this is another testimony
to how there are
sudden breakthroughs.
It should've been obvious.
But somehow people didn't
think of it.
Then, I found one
thing though.
I did a search on ngrams on
"eggs in one basket." There's
an old adage, "Don't put all
your eggs in one basket." And
that's kind of what we're coming
to with Markowitz here.
He's got a whole theory of it,
but I found an investment
manual from 1874 --
I can't find it here --
This is from a book, 1874,
about investing.
"There is an old saying that is
inadvisable to put all your
eggs in one basket." So, it was
already in there and he
says diversify.
OK?
And then he's done.
He doesn't tell you, how
do you diversify?
How do I know what
I should do?
It just stops there.
There was no theory of
risk until 1952.
So, let's think about that.
You see the concept I have?
You know all the variances.
This isn't a judgment thing.
You know all the covariances.
What should I do?
The first thing I want to talk
about is the very simple case
of pure leverage.
Let's go back to 1602.
OK.
And there's only one
stock, that's VOC.
OK, and there has to be
something else, otherwise
there's nothing --
The other thing I'm
going to say is
there's an interest rate.
Riskless interest rate.
So, I can invest in, let's say,
Dutch government bonds,
which are completely safe.
Some other person might say
they're not completely safe,
but they're much
safer than VOC.
VOC was wild.
The price was going all
over the place.
So let's, as an approximation,
say there's an interest rate.
You can borrow and lend
at the interest rate.
We'll call the riskless
rate r sub f.
OK?
And let's say, that's
5% a year.
OK?
We're investing for one year.
So, I can invest at the interest
rate and this is a
boring investment.
It's just getting interest.
It's 5%.
But I can also borrow at
the interest rate.
There's a market rate, and
I can borrow at 5%.
You know in practice, I would
probably have to pay a little
bit more as a borrower than I
could get as an investor.
But let's assume that away.
There's just an interest rate,
and anybody who wants to can
borrow and lend at the
interest rate.
I'll make it 5% just
for a round number.
OK.
And let's say VOC, the Dutch
East India Company, has had a
historic average
return of 20%.
This is a spectacular
investment, right?
But let's say it is, so that's
its mean, its mu, the mean of
the investment.
But let's say, it's really
risky, so the standard
deviation is 40%.
All right?
So, what can I do?
Suppose I have only -- this is
the first -- let's do the
simple problem first, OK?
I have only one asset, VOC,
and I have riskless debt.
I'm going to draw a chart
here showing --
I'm going to do sigma on this
axis, and r on this axis.
So, sigma is the standard
deviation of my portfolio, OK?
And r is the expected return
on the portfolio, OK?
And all I'm going to do is
choose mixtures of the stock
and the riskless rate.
So, for a couple of points,
I'm going to plot what the
available options are.
I can see right there that I can
invest at 5%, right, the
riskless rate, and then
I'll have no risk.
So, do you see this?
This is r sub f.
This is 0, OK, and these
are positive numbers.
See what I've plotted here?
This is just the most
boring investment.
Because there's no risk at
all, and I'm earning 5%.
I can also plot this
one, right?
So, here is VOC.
Is this big enough for you
to see back there?
OK.
So, VOC is up here, and this
is a risk of 40, and a
standard deviation of 20.
Sorry, an expected return of
20 and a risk of 40, right?
So, those are two points, but
I can do other things, too.
What if I borrowed
money to buy --
Let's say I have 100 guilders.
I'm talking Dutch.
OK, that was the currency of
the time, the guilder.
I'll write it for you.
Guilder.
OK.
So, I have 100 guilders to
invest. I could put it all on
VOC stock, and I would expect to
get 20 guilders profit, and
I'd have a standard deviation
of 40 guilders, right?
But what if I said, I'm
going to actually
borrow another 100 guilders.
I only own 100 guilders, but
I'm going to borrow another
100 guilders and put
it in VOC stock.
That means I'll own 200
guilders of VOC stock.
And I'm going to have a
debt of 100 guilders.
So, what's my expected
return then?
Well, my expected return
is going to be 35%.
Because, look, I'm owner of 200
guilder's of VOC stock.
The expected return is 20%, so
I'm going to get 40 guilders
out of that.
But then I have a debt.
I've got to pay five guilders
to my lender.
So, 35 is what I've got.
And as a percent of my initial
investment, that's 35%.
So, I've got another
point out here.
This is 35 and down
here is 80.
See my standard deviation is
80 guilders now, right?
Because I have 200 dollars
and the standard
deviation was 40%.
Right?
Here, I am 2-for-1 leveraged.
I have $100 but I've put
$200 in the stock.
OK, it's easy to do.
You know, you could
do this in 1602.
So, you can see, obviously, this
is a straight line here.
I can do anything along
this straight line.
Here would be putting half of my
money in the riskless asset
and half into the VOC.
This would be putting 1 1/2,
150 guilders, in VOC and
borrowing 50 guilders.
See, I can go out as
far as I want.
Then, there's another
branch to this.
What if I short 200 guilders
of VOC stock, OK.
So, I go to the broker, and I
say, I want to sell VOC stock.
I don't own any.
And the broker would say, all
right, fine, I'll lend you
some shares and then
you can sell them.
But you owe me the shares,
all right?
So, then I have minus 200
guilders worth of VOC stock.
So, what is my expected
return then?
And meanwhile, by the way, the
broker says, after you sell
the shares, I will get 200
guilders from the person who
bought them from you, and I'll
hold that, and I'll pay you
interest on that.
OK.
So, what do I get?
I expect to lose 40 guilders,
because I've got $200, 200
guilders of the stock.
But meanwhile, I've got my
original 100 guilders, and now
I've got another 200, and
they're all there earning
interest at 5%.
So, I will get 15 guilders.
So, the expected return is
15 minus 40, or minus 25.
So, that's this point
down here.
But you can see that you can
also do anywhere you
like on that line.
So, what we have here is
a broken straight line.
I can get anything
I want, right?
This is kind of obvious
right now.
Anywhere I want on that line, on
that broken straight line.
And I can do that.
So, here's where you got saying,
what is the optimal
portfolio anyway?
I can get any return I want.
You know, my client, who's
asking me to invest, says, I
want 100% return, expected.
You say, got it.
I'm no genius, right?
I'm just doing the most
obvious thing.
Anyone who wants a 100%
return can get it.
I'm just going to leverage.
So, then I create
an investment.
If I have an investment company
that merely buys VOC
stock and leverages it, my
investment company can have
any expected return
that you want.
So, this is what Markowitz
was wondering about.
What does it mean to have the
optimal investment anyway?
And the core thing that he
talked about in 1952 is, there
is no best investment.
There's only a trade-off between
risk and return.
And we have to think about
the best trade-off.
In this case, I've shown
the trade-off here.
This is what you can get.
Any one of those points
is available.
And so, anyone who wants to
invest with you has to choose
between risk and return.
There's no optimal portfolio
in that fundamental sense.
It's a matter of an
optimal trade-off.
And, you know, nobody knew
that before 1952.
So, let me just show
formally this --
what I just did on
the blackboard.
I've switched to dollars
from guilders.
Now we're in the USA.
And so, put x dollars in a risky
asset, 1 minus x dollars
in the riskless asset.
The expected value of the return
on the portfolio is r.
That's equal to x r1 plus 1
minus x times rf, all right?
It's linear, that's
because that's how
expected values work.
The variance is x squared
times the
variance of the return.
And so, if I want to write the
portfolio standard deviation
as a function of the expected
return, I solve for x.
Taking this equation for x,
solve for x in terms of r.
So, x equals r minus rf
all over r1 minus rf.
And then, I substitute that
in to this equation.
Well, I want to take the square
root of it, because
this is sigma squared.
And so, I've got sigma equals
r minus rf times r1 minus rf
[correction: this fraction is
multiplied by the standard
deviation of portfolio
return 1].
Well actually, I have these
absolute value marks.
If that's negative, I switch
sign and make it positive.
So, that gives the formula for
this broken straight line
right here.
So that's pretty simple.
That's the expected value
[correction: portfolio
standard deviation].
So now, I want to move ahead,
move on from this
simple idea to --
we haven't really gotten fully
into Markowitz yet.
Because this is a very
simple story.
By the way, this broken straight
line is what we call
a degenerate case
of a hyperbola.
You know the, remember in math,
hyperbola is a curve, a
certain mathematical curve.
And we're seeing a hyperbola
here, but I'm going to show
you other hyperbolas
in a minute.
What Markowitz really said --
well OK, this is simple.
This is all, just pure leverage
is a simple thing to
understand.
By the way, it's also called
gearing in the United Kingdom.
But let's think about now --
suppose I have more than
one risky asset.
Let's get past the year 1602.
And let's think about assets
in a more modern context.
I want to move to another
example, which
is two risky assets.
We've moved past 1602 and
now we have two stocks.
And for the moment, I'm going
to forget about leverage.
And let's just say you can put
x1 in the first risky asset,
that's stock number one.
And I can put 1 minus x1 in
the second risky asset.
That's stock number two.
OK?
So, what do I get here?
The portfolio expected return is
just the linear combination
of the two expected returns.
So, r1 is the expected return on
the first stock, and r2 is
the expected return on
the second stock.
Well actually, I'm assuming
you have $1 to
invest in this example.
I'm sorry.
I was assuming you had 100
guilders over there.
Now, I just made it $1.
Unrealistically small amount,
but I just wanted a nice
number, OK?
So, let's say $1 is 100
guilders, and then I haven't
changed anything.
OK.
So, I start out with $1, so if
I put x1 dollars in the first
one, I have 1 minus x1 left
for the other one.
So it's very simple.
And this is the formula for the
variance of the portfolio,
which we saw --
essentially we saw that
in the second lecture.
So, what I can do is, go through
the same sort of
exercise I did there with two
risky assets, all right?
And so, what I want to
do is, draw a curve
something like this.
But I'll solve for x1 in terms
of r, just like I did for the
riskless asset.
And I'll plug it into the
equation for the variance.
I'll have to take the square
root of that, and I
can plot that, OK?
And you might think it would
look something like that.
Well, it's not going to look
exactly like that, because
it's risky.
Something's risky.
So, I did that.
And incidentally on your problem
set, you're going to
have to think about
issues like this.
But what I did is, I took data
on the average return for the
U.S. stock market, as
measured by the S&P
500, and the variance.
And then, the alternate
investment I took was 10-year
treasuries for the United
States government.
Long-term, because they're
10 years, but we're only
investing for one year.
So, they're risky, because the
market price goes up and down.
They're not riskless.
I call those bonds.
There's other kinds of bonds.
And I computed the relationship
between the
standard deviation of the
portfolio and the expected
return, just as I showed you.
Again, using data from
1983 to 2006.
And it kind of looks like
this curve, doesn't it?
Except, this is a degenerate
parabola, but
it looks like this.
I'm sorry, parabola.
I said it wrong.
Hyperbola.
You know how hyperbola --
remember this from math?
Hyperbolas, well they look like
that, and they approach
asymptotes, which are
straight lines.
So, here is the hyperbola
for stocks and bonds.
So, just as I had a point here
which represented 100% VOC, I
can have over here
a point which
represents 100% U.S. stocks.
OK?
And I can take another
point which is 100%
bonds, that's here.
This point is 25% stock,
75% bonds.
This point is 50% stock,
50% bonds.
OK?
This is the choice set that I
as an investor have between
stocks and bonds.
So, is that clear?
You see, all these are
different portfolios.
If you're just going to do
stocks and bonds and nothing
else, what you choose to do
depends on your taste, on your
risk tolerance.
I could go 100% stocks,
but I'm going to
have a lot of risk.
I'm going to have a nice
expected return, it looks like
it's about 13%, 14%.
But I'm going to have
a high variance.
Looks like it's about 18%.
This is the S&P 500
stock market.
And so, it has a lot
of variance.
I could be safe, and I could
go all in bonds.
I could be here.
Then I'd have, you know, a
lower, much lower return, but
I'd have a lower variance.
So, what should I do?
Well, what do you
learn from it?
First of all, you learn there
isn't any single optimal
portfolio, but there
is something.
Let's talk about being
100% bond investor.
What do you think of that?
Is that a good idea?
You get this point right here.
Well, you definitely should not
be a 100% bond investor.
That's one thing we
just learned.
Why's that?
Because if I go up here, I have
no more -- see that's the
same standard deviation, the
same risk, but I have higher
return, right?
Higher expected return.
So, what did we just learn?
We learned that if you just stay
in this space of stocks
and bonds, maybe you could be
100% stock investor, but never
in a million years should you
ever even think of being 100%
bond investor.
OK, because, look, it's
just simple math.
I can figure it out.
I can figure out that I
get a higher expected
return and no more risk.
So, this is lesson number one
that Markowitz showed us.
Amazing.
It's so simple and
obvious, right?
It's not so simple, because, at
the time Markowitz wrote,
Yale University was probably
100% bond investor,
believe it or not.
They couldn't figure it
out in those days.
So, we've made progress.
That's why I think Markowitz is
among the most deserving of
the Nobel Prize winners
in economics.
This is really basic.
It actually intrigues me.
I don't know how much you like
math, but going back to my
childhood I was interested
in geometry.
These simple mathematical
curiosities like hyperbolas
are just fascinating to me.
It goes back to Apollonius of
Perga, writing in around 200
BC, wrote a book on
conic sections.
And he invented the words
hyperbola, parabola, ellipse.
So, I was thinking of looking
back at his book.
I think it still survives.
And see what it says
about finance.
But I can be sure he had no
idea that his theory would
apply to finance.
I wish I could go back in a time
machine and talk to him.
He would be so happy to know
that his theory of conic
sections --
It, you know, it ended up
applied to astronomy by Kepler
and Newton.
And now it hits into finance.
Isn't it amazing how there's
a unity of thought?
And this simple diagram
has just taught us
something about investing.
That's not obvious.
Not obvious until you
think about it.
I've just told you, never
invest only in bonds.
But it doesn't tell you
how much stocks
and how much bonds.
You know, once you're above this
point, it seems to be a
matter of taste.
There isn't any single decision
that you can make.
So, I want to move to a more
complicated world where we
have three assets.
OK.
We're starting from -- we had
one risky asset, then we had
two, now let's go
even further.
Let's say three risky assets.
Well, the expected return
is the same, it's
the weighted average.
Now we have three weights,
x1, x2, and x3, and they
have to sum to $1.
I could have written x3 as
1 minus x1 minus x2.
I wrote it differently here.
It looked messy to write
it the other way.
And this is the formula for
the portfolio variance.
It's the x1 squared, times the
variance of the return on the
first risky asset, plus x2
squared, times the variance of
the return on the second risky
asset, plus x3 squared, times
the variance of the return
on the third risky asset.
And then you have three more
terms representing
covariances.
You have to take account of the
covariances of the assets.
Because if they move together,
if they all go in the same
direction at the same time,
that's going to make your
portfolio riskier.
And so, that's the portfolio
variance.
And the portfolio expected
return is just --
why didn't I write it there?
It's x1r1 plus x2r2 plus
x3r3, where the sum of
the x's is 1, $1.
So, it's something that you can
do to calculate what is
the optimal portfolio.
So, I decided to add a third
asset to my diagram.
The pink line up here
is the same.
We call that an Efficient
Portfolio Frontier.
I have that in the title
of the slide,
for stocks and bonds.
That's the pink line here.
But I've added the Efficient
Portfolio
Frontier for three assets.
Stocks, bonds, and oil.
Oil is an important investment,
because our
economy runs on it.
And the total value of oil in
the ground is comparable to
the value of the stock
markets of the world.
It's big and important.
So, let's put that in.
And what I have actually here
is the minimum variance
mixture for any given expected
return for the three assets.
And you can see that it's
possible, when you add a third
asset, oil, to bring the
Efficient Portfolio Frontier
to the left.
OK?
Because we've got
another asset.
And it's also paying
a good return.
And it's not correlated.
Oil doesn't correlate very much
with the stock market.
So, we're spreading the risk
out over more assets.
We're putting more eggs
in our basket.
[Correction: We are providing
more baskets for the eggs.]
OK?
And so, we have a better
choice set now, right?
We can pick any point
on that blue line.
And so, we shouldn't just
have stocks and bonds.
We've learned we should have
stocks, bonds, and oil.
We're leading toward a
fundamental insight, which is
due to Markowitz, which is,
the more the merrier.
The more different kinds of
assets you can put in, the
lower you can get the standard
deviation of your return, for
any given expected return.
So, the better off you are.
This is diversification.
So, while diversification was
applauded in the nineteenth
century, no one had ever done
the math like this before.
And now we can see, when you do
the math, you want to have
all three in your portfolio.
And yet people don't
know that.
They don't, there's an emotional
resistance to this
implication.
I once went to the government
of Norway.
I gave a talk at their Norges
Bank, which is the central
bank of Norway.
I told them in my talk, I
calculate that Norway has
something like 70% of its
portfolio in oil.
I don't remember the exact
number, but it was something
close to that.
Why do they have
so much in oil?
Well, because they have
the North Sea Oil.
And so, I asked them at the
bank, don't you realize, where
are you on this portfolio?
You're not on the frontier.
What Norway should be doing is
something like 15%, they could
pick this point right, that
would be reasonable.
15% oil, 53% stocks, 32% bonds,
which would give them
that point.
Or they could pick this one.
I have a point labeled
up here.
That's 21% oil, 79%
stocks, no bonds.
All right, those are all
choices depending
on your risk tolerance.
But they're not going to
just pick 100% oil.
That would be way over here,
much higher risk.
So, I asked them about that.
Why do you do this?
And I don't know if I got a
good answer from them, but
basically it was, well, we don't
want to sell the oil,
because it's our national
heritage, you know, we own it.
And I said, well you don't have
to sell it, you can just
do a derivative transaction.
You can short the futures
market for oil
and reduce your exposure.
And then, they said, well, some
people have mentioned
that, but its politically
difficult.
So, they're not doing it.
Maybe next year.
Maybe the next government
will do that.
So, they still aren't
there yet.
They're not managing
their risks well.
So, it's a powerful and
important thing, because if
the market for oil collapses,
Norway is in big trouble.
They're not diversifying
enough.
I don't mean to put them down.
They're smart people, but
like in any country --
I did the same thing
with Mexico.
I went to the Banco de Mexico.
And I talked to Guillermo
Ortiz when he
was director of it.
Same thing in Mexico.
It's not as dependent on oil,
not as dependent on
oil as Norway is.
It's not so obvious
for Mexico.
But it is politics
that came in.
The question of, are you really
saying Mexico should go
into the futures market and take
a massive short-position
of billions of dollars of oil?
Again, it was like, this
isn't reality.
We're not going to do that.
But I tried to make the point.
Now, another thing is, I have
shown here three assets.
The pink line is irrelevant once
we realize we have three
assets, we have stocks,
bonds, and oil.
So, you should choose
on this curve.
And a person should never
take down here, even
though that's possible.
In other words, you could say,
what portfolio would give me
9% return with the least risk?
Well it turns out
it's 100% bonds.
But I just told you, never do
100% bonds, because you can go
up to this point, all right?
So, you never do down here.
So, the Efficient Portfolio
Frontier is really the part of
the hyperbola that's above
the minimum variance.
And you don't want
to do minimum
variance either, right?
This is the lowest possible
risk portfolio.
You can't get down to
zero risk if all of
your assets are risky.
So, you're stuck here.
That's not necessarily the best
thing, because people
allow some risk.
This is having the minimum risk,
but I can get my return
up much higher without
taking much risk, so
I'd probably do that.
OK.
Now, I can do this with more
than three assets.
I can do it with 1,000 assets,
now that we have computers.
Back in 1952, I erased it, but I
had 1952 here, Markowitz had
do it all by hand.
But now that we have computers,
it's so easy.
You know, there are all kinds of
programs. In fact, on your
problem set, we have Wolfram
Alpha, which will do all these
calculations for you
for its own data.
These are easy to do now.
But what I want to do now is
add the riskless asset.
So, what we've done, the blue
line takes three risky assets.
It looks only at assets with
a standard deviation
greater than zero.
Now I want to do the optimal
portfolio when
there are four assets.
I've got stocks, bonds,
oil, all risky.
And now I have the thing that
isn't risky, would be your
1-year governments.
Right?
It's not risky, because
the maturity matches
my investment horizon.
I know exactly what
I'm going to get.
It's 5%, let's say.
So, what can I do investing
in these for assets?
Well, here it goes back to what
I did over here with this
simple diagram.
I can pick any portfolio on
the Efficient Portfolio
Frontier and consider that as
if that were VOC, right?
And then, I can compute just
how leverage allows me to
combine that with the riskless
asset and that portfolio.
So, I can pick a point, like
I can pick this point here.
And then, I could achieve, by
combining that portfolio,
which is 15% oil, 53% stocks,
and 32% bonds --
I could combine that with any
amount of risky debt.
And I would get a straight
line going between --
actually, this diagram doesn't
show zero, I should have maybe
done it differently --
but between 5% --
So, actually that point
right here.
You can do it on this diagram.
That point here is
like 12% expected
return and 8% variance.
So, it would be some --
well, it would be here, except
this would be 12% and this
would be 8%.
I can pick any point.
And this would be 5%.
Any point along the straight
line connecting those points
is possible.
So, what do I want to do?
I want to get the highest
expected return for any
standard deviation.
I want to take a line that goes
through 5% on the y-axis
and is as high as possible.
So, I'm taking a point right
over here, at 5%, and trying
to get as high as I can.
It turns out then, that I want
to pick the point which has a
tangency with the Efficient
Portfolio Frontier.
And so, that means the highest
straight line that touches the
Efficient Portfolio Frontier.
And so, now I can achieve
any point on that line.
And that's again Markowitz's
insight.
So, if I were to pick that
point, I would be --
What does it look like?
I don't have it indicated.
Probably something like 11% oil,
30% stocks, 50% bonds,
something like that,
it doesn't add up.
And that would be holding
no debt, right?
[Clarification: No debt, in
the sense of shorting the
risk-free rate.]
But I could get even higher
returns, if my client wants
that, by leveraging.
I would borrow and buy even more
of this risky portfolio.
So, this portfolio here is
called the Tangency Portfolio.
And what Markowitz's theory
shows is that, once you add
the risky asset
[correction: riskless asset],
the relevant Efficient Portfolio
Frontier is now
really this tangency line.
And so, I want to do a mixture
of the riskless asset and the
Tangency Portfolio that
accords with my risk
preferences.
But I don't want to ever just
move to one of these other
portfolios.
You see, these other portfolios,
like 15% oil, 53%
stock, 32% bonds, is dominated,
has a higher
expected return for the same
risk, by a portfolio of the
Tangency Portfolio, leveraged up
a little bit by borrowing.
I don't know if it was clear in
Markowitz's paper, but it
became clear soon after.
There really is, in a sense,
an optimal portfolio.
It's the Tangency Portfolio.
Because everyone wants to invest
on this line, and any
point on this line is a mixture
of the riskless asset
and the Tangency Portfolio.
And so, everyone wants to invest
in the same portfolio.
So, there is an optimal
portfolio, in a sense.
It's in a sense that everybody
wants to do the same risky
investments.
People will differ in their risk
preferences, and so some
of them will want to do a
riskier, a more leveraged
version, and some of them will
do a less leveraged version of
the Tangency Portfolio, but
everyone wants to do the
Tangency Portfolio.
So, that is the key idea of
Markowitz's portfolio
management.
And it's been expressed
by some as
the Mutual Fund Theorem.
First of all, I have to just to
define for you, what is a
mutual fund?
You may not know that.
A mutual fund is a certain kind
of investment company
aimed at a retail audience.
They could have just called this
the investment company
theorem, but history --
I can't tell you the history
of thought on this.
A mutual fund is a certain kind
of investment company
that is mutual.
That means that the owners of
the shares in the fund are --
there's no other owners.
There's just one class
of investors.
You're all equal,
so it's mutual.
But that's irrelevant to you.
The idea is that, all we need
is one mutual fund.
There's thousands of mutual
funds to serve investors.
Because I had that everyone
is investing in
the Tangency Portfolio.
So, they should call
their fund the
Tangency Portfolio fund.
And our fund is the optimal mix
of stock, bonds, oil and
whatever else.
And then, you don't necessarily
want to own only
that mutual fund, but you want
to own mixtures of that mutual
fund and the riskless asset.
So, you only need one
investment company.
See, I told you this story.
I said, imagine that you were
mathematically inclined, and
you have all the statistics,
and you're going
to figure it out.
What's the best thing to do?
We've just figured it out.
I haven't gone through
all the math details.
There is a best thing to do.
You should offer, as your
investment product, the
Tangency Portfolio.
And that's it.
Once you've figured it out,
there's nothing more to do.
There's no need to hire any
more finance people.
You've figured it
out, according
to Markowitz's theory.
And all the investors in
the world will just
invest in this one.
And that's it.
Case closed.
We don't need thousands
of mutual funds.
Under the assumptions of
Markowitz, which is that we're
agreed on the variances, and
covariances, and expected
returns, there's a single
optimal risky portfolio.
And then the instructions to
investors are very simple.
All you need is two assets
in your portfolio.
The mutual fund that owns the
Tangency Portfolio, and
whatever amount of
debt you want.
So, if you're footloose and
fancy free, you can even
leverage it.
You can borrow and do
2-to-1, 3-to-1,
it's up to your tastes.
But you don't need to look
at anything other
than the mutual fund.
So, that's an important
insight.
And what it means then --
that leads to something else.
Markowitz didn't
get this idea.
It came out later.
Someone was thinking, if
everyone should be investing
in the same portfolio, it
doesn't add up unless that
that portfolio is equal to the
total assets out there in the
world, right?
If there's twice as much oil as
there is stock, then there
has to be twice as much
oil as stock in
the Tangency Portfolio.
Otherwise, it doesn't
add up, right?
Everyone has to own
everything.
Supply and demand
have to equal.
So it means, the Mutual Fund
Theory implies that the market
portfolio equals the Tangency
Portfolio, OK.
And now I've pretty much
finished the theory.
I should say, it implies, if
investors follow this model
that we're having.
That they all want to --
that Markowitz's model --
If all investors think like
Markowitz says, they all want
to do the same thing.
They all want to invest in
the same best portfolio.
So, that has to be proportional
to the market portfolio.
So, the Tangency Portfolio
equals the market portfolio.
So, I was saying earlier, why
is it that everyone doesn't
invest in VOC stock?
How does it add up, right?
If VOC stock is just better than
something else, then that
suggests everyone wants to put
all their money in VOC stock.
But we're realizing,
they don't.
Because they're concerned
about it.
They see this trade-off between
risk and return, and
they want to hold some
proportion of VOC stock and
the riskless asset.
It has to add up, so that the
market is cleared and all the
VOC stock is owned.
And more generally, if there
are many assets, all the
assets have to end up
owned by someone.
So, the cardinal implication
of this theory is that the
market portfolio, which is
everything that's out there in
the world to invest in, has
to be proportional to the
Tangency Portfolio [correction:
has to be equal
to the Tangency Portfolio].
And so, one of the
implications is,
if that's true --
and I have just a couple
more slides here.
Now it's called the
Capital Asset
Pricing Model in finance.
So, that's Capital Asset --
which is a pricing model, which
was not invented by
Markowitz, but was invented by
Sharpe and Lintner somewhat
shortly after Markowitz.
The Capital Asset
Pricing Model --
and I'm not going to derive
this equation.
But it says the expected return
on any asset, the i-th
asset, equals the risk free
rate, plus the beta of that
asset times the difference
between the expected return on
the market and the expected
return on the riskless asset.
I was just going to try to
explain this intuitively, and
then I'll be done.
I have one more slide about
the Sharpe ratio.
But the intuitive idea -- let me
just say, everything should
have a very simple
explanation.
And the intuitive idea is this:
Starting from Markowitz,
we got an understanding
of what risk is.
People didn't clearly
appreciate that.
People used to think
that risk was
uncertainty, right, in finance.
If a stock has a lot of
uncertainty, that uncertainty
means that it's a dangerous
stock, and people will demand
a high expected return,
otherwise they
won't hold the stuff.
But the CAPM says no, people
don't care about the
uncertainty of the stock.
Because if it's one stock out
of many, they'll put it in
their portfolio, and if it's
independent of everything
else, it all gets averaged
out, and so, who cares?
So, people don't care
about variance.
Well, what is it that
people care about?
People care about covariance.
This is the basic insight that
followed from Markowitz.
People care about how much a
stock moves with the market,
because that's what costs
me something.
I don't care, I can own a
million little stocks that all
have independent risk.
It all averages out, doesn't
mean anything to me.
I'll put them in tiny quantities
in my portfolio.
But if they correlate with the
market, I can't get rid of the
risk, because it's the
big picture risk.
That's what insurance companies,
that's what
everyone cares about.
It's this market risk.
The big risk.
You only care about how much a
stock correlates with the big
picture in its risk.
So, that's measured by beta.
The beta is the regression --
the slope coefficient, when you
regress the return on the
i-th asset on the return
of the market.
So, high beta stocks are stocks
that go with the market.
We found out that Apple has a
beta of 1.5, or roughly that.
That means, they respond
in an exaggerated way.
It's not 1, it's greater than
1, they more than move with
the market.
And so, investors will demand
a higher return on Apple
stock, because its beta is
greater than for other stocks.
That's the core idea
that underlies it.
Do you see that intuitively?
You have to change your
idea of what risk is.
Risk is covariance.
It's co-movements.
I have just one more
slide here.
It's named after William Sharpe,
who is the inventor,
with Lintner, of the Capital
Asset Pricing Model.
The Sharpe ratio is, for any
portfolio, the average return
on the portfolio minus the
risk-free rate, divided by the
standard deviation
of the portfolio.
And if you take the CAPM model,
the Sharpe ratio is
constant along the
tangency line.
This is a way of correcting the
average return from some
investment for leverage.
The idea is --
Some companies used to
advertise, we've had a 15%
average return, and then
investors would
say, but wait a minute.
You didn't tell me what
your leverage is.
That's the first thing you
should learn from this course.
Someone advertises that they had
15% return, you say, ha, I
want to know what your
leverage was.
I want to know --
you were just leveraging it up
and taking big risks, and on
average you'll do well,
but it's risky.
So, this is the correction
you make.
How do you correct
for leverage?
You might say, well I want to
look at what fraction of the
investment portfolio is in the
risky asset, and what fraction
is in the riskless asset.
But it's not so easy to do that,
because the company can
cover up its tracks.
It can invest in a company
that's leveraged, right?
And so, you have to go one
step further and undo the
leverage for that company.
It's hard to do that.
But the easy thing to do is
just calculate the Sharpe
ratio for the investment
company.
So, if some guy is investing and
is claiming to have done
15% of return per year on his
portfolio, well, I'm going to
look at the standard deviation
of the portfolio.
That's evidence of how leveraged
this guy was.
And I compute the
Sharpe ratio.
And unless it's bigger than the
Sharpe ratio for the, you
know, the typical stock,
I'm not impressed.
Anyway, so I think, I've come
to the end of this lecture.
So, what you should have gotten
from this lecture is a
concept of risk return
trade-off, a concept of
optimal portfolio as being
something subtle and related
to Apollonius of Perga
in difficult ways.
But there's also very simple
things about how to evaluate
portfolios and portfolio
managers that
comes out of this.